J'aime une grande histoire d'amour puissante
vraiment intense et sophistiquée c'est ainsi que
je voulais faire tout le film l'
histoire de base est une femme très privée et
honorable rencontre un homme qui a beaucoup de
succès et puissant jutsu amis
maladie anesthésie finit par être invité
à l'interviewer  pour l'
audience du journal universitaire qu'elle rencontre ce
gars que tout le monde veut savoir sur
mr.  gray va te voir maintenant elle n'est pas
comme les femmes dont il
s'entoure elle finit par être assez prise
par lui comme il l'est avec son Christian Grey
je suis Anastasia Steele un fromage c'est une
histoire d'amour va-et-vient de boue au
début  nous construisons un sentiment de sécurité complet le
soir Ellen sentant ce que tu voles
je trouve que tu es intimidé tu devrais Eve
sans parler autoritaire nous partons ensuite dans
un voyage émotionnel très profond entre
deux personnes qui essaient de compter avec
quelle est la relation et quelle
est la relation mes goûts sont très
singuliers éclairez-moi alors c'est tout un
voyage pour elle pour l'honneur chrétien Dom
Laxus trous je Timothy enfreint tant de
ses propres règles, c'est une personne endommagée
tout ce succès et extérieur d'acier tout
commence à s'effondrer j'ai besoin de plus j'en veux
plus ce n'est pas quelque chose que je connais
qui grandit en intensité construit sur
des liens très puissants
c'est très riche c'est séduisant et c'est
romantique
c'est un film sexy ça devait être un fantasme
cl  assy exaltant j'espère juste que cela
honore ce que les gens veulent du film
c'est ce que vous voulez